here is a voicemail from a trumpist
asking a question that i think is worthy
of discussion
a little bit uh take a listen to this
hey david uh i've called your show a few
times before
uh and left voicemail so kind of happy
to do it again
so anyways i was just curious about a
particular thing
uh as a jewish man yourself
uh how can you find yourself not
supporting donald trump
so i'd like to explain that first of all
as a voter
of donald trump i voted for him for an
america first
foreign policy right so my question
well and he has broadly pursued an
agenda that's been pro-israel
pro-zionist and my question to you is
that as a jew it seems like he's done a
lot for your
people my people um so i was just
curious about that
no trump has done nothing for my people
let this is this is a great opportunity
to uh to to explain uh american jews
are very liberal one of the most liberal
voting blocs in the country
and our priorities are left
priorities to different degrees you've
got center left and more progressive
okay whatever
what donald trump has done with regard
to israel
is the same unproductive nonsense that
benjamin netanyahu has done which is
virtue signaling not so much to jews
but to these evangelical christians
who have this messianic view
of what needs to happen in israel moving
the m if you're an american progressive
jew and you see trump move the embassy
from tel aviv to jerusalem that does
nothing for me and in fact it's an
impediment to peace
it's an impediment to peace so the
framing
is completely wrong trump for for my
people
trump has done nothing and in fact
trump's presidency
has normalized the types of extremism
that lead to more out in the open
anti-semitism so the framing could not
be more wrong
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about wait a second
are democrats looking at impeaching
trump again
what is the point of that let's discuss
nine million americans
still haven't received their stimulus
checks and
new york is among cities losing
financing
by being designated anarchist cities
by trump's justice department all of
those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a 10 a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com pacman